[Music]
so
so with organic pesticide this one you
make it with the local available word
materials
when you're using the organic pesticide
if you also cut the water if you have
the cost of production because you're
not going to spend some other money in
buying some other
pesticides of that vegetable all you are
enemy they are confessed
so
what you are producing as vegetable is a
food for something
so that those living organisms we can
come and feed on our plant either by
sucking the gross almond or by eating
the leaves
or by eating the fruits and today we are
showing you
how to control
the infestation of pests in our
vegetables using organic material
organic material meals
you prepare it in the absence of kevin
there is no chemical component here the
whole chemical will come from the
solution
will act like chemical commercial family
for that in the best okay
so
we want to know how to prepare it
locally so that you are able to make
sure that you control pests
at the reduced cost or at low cost
as you maximize profit in your
production okay
so the materials here
are the things that we are going to use
these are all available
from today when you go back you have to
plant aloe vera red pepper you have to
plant bread better
right now you are producing onions okay
if the onion the real bulb is not there
you can use the leaves
okay onion beans can also work well
because of its fungus
[Music]
sometimes you wonder why people plant
flowers around the corner there are some
flowers
for us
something to beautify the hand to make
your problem look beautiful
but today is not only making your
comfort look beautiful it will make your
body to look beautiful
because when the garden is having pests
all over
[Music]
organic pesticides for example i have
aloe vera here in my hand
which is used
as a fertilizer because it has
ingredients like mathematics
potassium
and many harvest it also
control
and many other festive
caterpillars beetles and
this is a red pepper
alpine filling one of the materials used
in making our organic persistent
in this in this filipina
it is when we are using in five liters
of water we take one cup of filipinos we
found it and we put it in our container
milipeli contains the active ingredients
which helps in controlling athletes
caterpillars
and
and also beetles
and it's called
marigold
when you using it
you get like uh
five cups of the leaves
how you found it
after pounding you put it in your
container the marigold are the active
ingredients that works on
our first like the
the caterpillars
and the cat worms
so they are actually used in controlling
those
pests
in our crops
is one of the materials among them and
here i'm having neem leaf it works
in thing like
control of fungus diseases
bananas weevils
today i'm very very happy because we are
learning about how to make
organic
pesticides
in behind here i have
tomatoes leaves when you pound it then
mix it with other substances that is
used in making organic pesticides and it
is
some it brings some irritation in
insects and definitely kills the insect
like it
helps in controlling
face like heartwarm
caterpillars
and the rest of it so we have many pets
that destroyed our crop so this one
would help a lot
if you're
very very proud to be here in a later
training
institute here is our one of our
material for making organic pesticide
this is onion balm if you want to make
it you can use this one something like
seven of them and in absence of that one
you can use the leaf something like half
of a kilo and this onion tab you can
take it to the mortar and then you pound
it
and from there this one it acts as a
repellent also
it is it controls what is so-called hand
both red and then
and then black and
not only that one it can also control
it can also control army warm
and then
up it and then cut one also so that is
all about the onion thank you
in case one of them
okay thank you very much in case of one
of the materials means maybe you don't
have the aloe vera
but you have the
you have the
like the
red pepper the red pepper can also work
on artists aloe vera can also work on
so in the absence of aloe vera you can
use that one
in the absence of the red pepper you can
use that
then you can drop one in the oven of the
tomatoes
[Music]
we're going to pound it after pounding
we water them when we keep in this
container for 3 days after 30 days we're
going to see the solution
and we use it for
again for spraying our crops in
depending
again the space like
caterpillars
this is how you are going to pound it if
you cannot pound like this you can chop
them chop them into small pieces
how you chop a green vegetable when
you're preparing it
so you make sure that the leaves are
broken
to leave
those inner contents to be able to
release their
uh substance into the water okay
so if you have water you can pound like
this now we have this one it's already
five five handful of the tomato leaves
okay
we are also going to add it here okay
you add it here
and then we found what
let us found aloe vera
aloe vera
we can even you can mix all this
material all together and you pound at
once if you have a bigger motor
i get to that so you can put this aloe
vera
[Music]
so you cut the onions we also found all
together the onion leaves okay
so why are we using onions
it's a repellent and it also controls
our foods okay
then we are going to put we are going to
also pound together one cup of
red pepper
pants carefully you have to be careful
otherwise
so remaining two onions
now
the process
the process of mixing all these things
together and then put add water into it
is to allow
what is called decoction
decoction it means
you have taken tea all right
the tea leaves is dry but when you put
in water
after sometimes you find the color of
that water change okay
it means
the solute the material then the
component of the tea leaves has gotten
into the water and change the color are
you getting that
so the active ingredients in these
materials
will get into the water the process of
this material this
in active ingredient getting into the
water is called the option okay
so the process of
for us to get what we need to control
first those active ingredients we must
keep it in water for 3
30 days okay
so we are going to keep it we are going
to stand it in water for feeding days
after 3 days we shall see
this material and then we get only the
solution down there okay
that solution has all the active
ingredients which will kill
different kind of pests
so long as we apply onto the
on to them okay so it will give us a
contact
pesticide
now you can see this is a mixture of
onions red pepper
and the
aloe vera okay no
you have to take care of your option
so you pour it here
good
then now you can put some water there
you rinse
pour water in the mortar and then you
also add it here
so i think this one doesn't doesn't
deserve only five liters
this material is too much
let us prepare a solution of 10 liter
out of this okay
later
so the only challenge with the organic
materials
we do not know exactly what quantity of
any active ingredient present in that
solution okay that is the problem
because we cannot be coming we don't
have the machine to determine to detect
the amount of
decoction or concoction
so
so you can see now we have put all the
material together
inside the container okay it is even
starting to irritate
i am hearing people are coughing
it means now
our pesticide has started working
it is starting to irritate your throat
and some of you will start shedding
tears okay so now this material is not
is more than
four five liter okay
let us add here ten liter of water
it is very concentrated okay
i told you that
this is a serious organic pesticide okay
i can see people are now coughing
it means
it means the the pesticide has started
working it is so irritating
it is so irritating such that when you
add onto
when you apply onto the pest the pest
will never survive okay
have you measured water
so we are preparing a solution of 10
liter okay
a 10 liter solution of organic pesticide
you can form
foreign
[Music]
so we have looked at the final
steps
the final step of preparing our organic
pesticide okay
[Music]
you